Welcome back everyone
Happy New Year
Matt Reeves and James Gunn revealed a bunch of details
about the upcoming Batman Arkham series
they're working on.
We learned more about the Batman 2
and Batman Brave and the Bold
like a lot of Batman related stuff
just going around this year,
including that Batman Penguin series
that will actually be getting episodes for.
There are a couple of big surprises
with how they're handling everything,
where everything fits in the timeline,
the different continuity, like which universe
is this going to be in the Batman universe
or the DCU movies
like Superman Legacy, Batman, Brave in The Bold.
So we'll break it all down in all the DC movies
and shows that are actually coming this year
that we're actually getting episode
four that'll actually premiering if you're brand
new to the channel, of course I'll be doing videos
for everything they wind up releasing.
There is a lot of DC stuff coming this year,
even though Superman Legacy isn't coming
till next year, like the Batman
two isn't coming till next year 2024, 2025.
Really big years for DC for a couple of reasons,
But probably.
The biggest surprise is that late last year, James
Gunn was answering all kinds of questions
about all of the upcoming DC movies
like Superman, Legacy, Batman, Brave in The Bold,
the Batman, too, with Robert Pattinson.
He's been really good about that.
Like he's really chatty with fans.
he confirmed that the Penguin HBO series
is firmly set inside the Matt Reeves
Robert Pattinson Batman universe
because it is Colin Farrell's version of the Penguin.
In all those characters that we saw
from the first Batman movie, some of the characters
will come back during the Batman 2,
But that's all still meant to be
self-contained in that Batman universe for elseworlds
in the rolling out like a brand new title
to play in front of Elseworlds movies
so that people that go see these things or like you
watch the episodes on television,
you'll know that they're Elseworlds
but the Batman Arkham series
that Matt Reeves is working on
will actually be connected to the DCU,
which is what James Gunn is calling his connected
Justice League universe of movies.
It's going to start with Creature commandos later
this year, then Superman Legacy in 2025,
including Batman Brave in the Bold,
Not the Robert Pattinson Batman movies.
this is a big surprise because everything that Matt
Reeves had been saying about the Batman Arkham series
right after that first Robert Pattinson Batman movie
came out in theaters a couple of years ago.
was that all the Arkham scenes
during that movie, the depiction of Arkham
just in general
would be followed up on in the Arkham series.
So people just assume,
it's going to take place in the Same universe.
Is the Penguin
HBO series is the Robert Pattinson Batman movies
part of the whole idea with this new Penguin
HBO series.
Is it meant to bridge the gap
between the first Batman movie in the Batman, too?
Like, there's a bit of a time gap Originally,
it sounded like after he was finished
with the Batman 2, that came out in 2025,
they do the Arkham series.
It would serve the same basic function bridging the gap
between the Batman two and whatever Robert
Pattinson's Batman three movie winds up being like
Batman versus the Court of Owls or something like that.
and they just use that Arkham series
to feature more of Robert Pattinson.
Batman's Rogues Gallery of villains
that we saw in the first two Batman movies
and some returning in the Batman three.
basically the same vibe as the Penguin HBO series.
and they just do multiple seasons of the shows
based on how they perform.
With the exception to the Colin Farrell Penguin series,
I don't see him doing
like five seasons of the Penguin
just because he does so many movies.
He's so booked up all the time.
But the Arkham series,
because it is a bit more general, like it's
not tied to any one specific Batman character.
They could do a bunch of seasons of that.
I would expect the main antagonist of that series
to at least start out being Hugo Strange
just because of the way the character works in
and around Arkham Asylum with all the other inmates.
Then they just bring in a revolving door of Batman's
rogues
gallery of villains that come through Arkham Asylum.
The bitter couple versions of Hugo Strange.
Most people will remember the last live action, one
being from the Gotham Series.
They spent a lot of time at Arkham Asylum.
Matt Reeves implied the
Barry Wilkins Joker Paladino's
Riddler, would come back during that Arkham series.
So everything seemed pretty cut and dry
the way it would all fit together.
It would work in their timeline.
like it all be part of that Robert Pattinson,
Batman Elseworlds universe.
But then out of nowhere, James Gunn drops a bomb.
The Batman Arkham series Matt Reeves was making
would actually be connected to his DCU Justice
League movies like Superman Legacy in Batman, Brave
in the Bold, not the Robert Pattinson Batman stuff.
as you would expect, typical James Gunn fashion.
He didn't really expand on his answer,
Like he just gave a very curt
answer like, No, no, no,
this is all meant to be connected to the DCU.
so it means one of two things is happening.
One, Matt Reeves is going to use
totally different versions of all the Batman characters
in the Arkham series that we'll see in Batman
Brave in the Bold, eventually a couple more years
down the road,
or eventually they're just going to connect the Robert
Pattinson Batman universe to the new Batman
Brave in the bold movie.
Somehow, let's say it's the younger version
of the Batman that we see in Batman Brave in the Bold,
which seems less likely like he started out
in that first Batman movie during Batman year or two.
The Batman two movie won't be that much later.
The Batman three also would not be that much later.
Like the time jumps wouldn't be that great.
So he'd still be in his twenties
for all of his franchise.
We know the Batman we're going to see in Batman.
Brave in the Bold is going to be a little bit older,
like Ben Affleck, Batman age,
because he'll be old enough to have had Damian Wayne.
We'll have the rest of the Batman family
that will have come and gone,
like Nightwing will already exist in this universe.
So a bunch of time has gone by in
one of the big things that James Gunn said
that he was trying to do with his new rebooted
DC movies was to simplify things
so that there weren't like ten different versions
of all the characters,
like ten different versions of Batman,
all flying around on screen at the same time.
Normally.
The simplest answer here is the correct one,
like which answer leads to James Gunn
and those people doing the least amount of work,
the least amount of explainer videos
that you have to watch in order to understand
how everything is connected.
in that means that the Arkham series is
probably is going to have totally different versions
of the characters
and really is going to be a totally different thing
separate from the Robert Pattinson Batman movies.
And I do think that the Batman that we meet in
Batman, braving the ball will be completely different
from Robert Pattinson and they'll just do
their own thing in the Matt Reeves Batman universe.
Probably get a trilogy eventually in success,
assuming that everything goes well with the Batman 2.
then after that,
the only live action Batman will be in Batman,
Brave in the Bold henceforth
for like the next 1015 years in success as well.
Like assuming that everything goes
well with James Gunn's new movies,
getting back to the place
where there is only one live action Batman.
so it kind of looks like we're actually getting
that Batman Arkham series, which is going to be candid
to Batman Brave in the Bold Before we get Batman,
Brave in the Bold, and before we learn
who that brand new version of Batman is going to be,
like I said,
the Bat-Family is supposed to already exist
when that movie is picking up.
They might not all be in the movie, But think about it
this way.
Damian Wayne is so far down on the totem
pole of Robin's.
Damian Wayne means we've already had Dick Grayson
who since become Nightwing.
Jason Todd has come and gone
looking out for Red Hood and James
Gunn's new movies because he would have already
had time to become Red Hood.
lot of you out there have been asking for a live action
Red Hood for a long, long time.
Tim Drake would have also come and gone,
maybe even some of the female Batman
sidekicks somewhere in there, too,
like the Bat family is big.
Damian Wayne is basically like the last Major Robin
to have debut in the comics
there was an entire bat
cave full of people before he came along.
know that they're all going to be in Batman
Brave in the Bold, like maybe Nightwing,
like maybe a little bit of the other Robin's.
But generally, Damian Wayne meant to be like
the second male lead next to Batman.
other thing about that too is it also means
we get a new older version of the Joker, for instance,
because Batman has aged up a little, it means
all of his villains have aged up a little too much.
So the Joker we see during that Batman Arkham series
wouldn't be the Barry Keoghan Joker either.
Let me know in the comments.
Now that we know the Arkham series is connected
to Batman Brave in the Bold, the DCU movies,
who do you want to play?
All these new versions of all the Batman villains?
A lot of people were asking for Willem Dafoe Joker
a long time ago when they first announced
the Matt Reeves movies before we saw Barry
Killian Joker, they could actually do.
Willem Dafoe.
Joker is like the older Joker
during Batman, Brave in the Bold
or whatever
future Batman movies in that connected universe.
I have this something I want to show.
but even though it's
going to be a couple of years
before we actually find out more about Batman
brave in the Bold, the other major DC movie series
coming this year actually start with that
Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths movie
that is definitely meant to be elseworlds.
It's meant to be the beginning of the end of the
tomorrow verse line of animated DC movies.
they're basically using that to reboot into James
Gunn's DCU
because of the new animated stuff
will be canon to the live action stuff.
That was his big thing,
like making it all connected to each other.
But next is the Joker two with Joaquin Phenix,
his Harley Quinn.
That's firmly elseworlds obviously.
Then we get the Batman Penguin series
that's releasing in the fall, probably around October.
then creature commandos at the very end of the year,
which is technically the first confirmed
Canon DCU project,
does part of James Gunn's new Justice League universe
The whole idea is the voiceover actors will come back
as their characters in the live action movies.
Eventually, they're engineering the shows to work
more like the Marvel Disney Plus series,
where usually, usually the movie actors
come back to voice their characters in animation.
2025.
Though Superman Legacy
is meant to be the first live action DCU project,
Blue Beetle was a bit of a weird scenario, though,
this past year where James Gunn was like,
All these characters can come back,
but the movie was made before he was hired.
A DC he didn't have any creative oversight over that
or anything like that,
only to prevent them
from causing any future headaches with continuity.
Like there were some very well-documented edits
that they made to the Post-Credits
scenes in the movies that came out this year
because it was the end of the DCU
like Alchemy and two was the very last DCU movie.
So they changed the Post-Credits
scene, got rid of all the Batman stuff.
They got rid of a lot of the Henry Cavill
Superman stuff in the Flash just to prevent them from
setting up stuff that they would never be paying off
because they were rebooting into the DCU.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming out though,
so if you have any questions about all the DC stuff
that's coming in the next couple of years, just write
in the comments below and I'll add them to my videos.
But don't worry, those of you that have been asking
for me to do more DC videos every week,
we will start getting some weekly DC series again
pretty soon.
Henry Cavill has that big Warhammer series
that he's working on
I just did a big video for that.
Click here to learn what's going on with that
and click here for my X-Men
97 teaser trailer video and Easter Eggs
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!